hey this is press to
Walker in this video I will share three
different problems about circles and
rectangles problem one from an
Australian math
competition a coin rolls on the interior
of a square along its sides without
slipping after the coin has returned to
its starting position the coin has made
one whole
Revolution if the coin's radius is equal
to one what is the side length of the
square equal
to problem two this comes from a math
kangaroo
competition a rectangle is divided by
two
circles the top side of the rectangle is
divided into three segments as is the
bottom side the three segments on the
top side have lengths of 8 26 and 22 on
the bottom side two lengths are equal to
12 and
24 what is the third length equal
to problem three this is from Twitter at
cshare
41 here's a circle and here are four
squares three of the areas are known at
16 25 and
100 what is the area of the
circle pause the video if you'd like to
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve these
[Music]
problems so let's solve problem
one now in the lower left corner we can
construct a square whose side length is
equal to the radius of the coin
now let the coin Roll Along the bottom
side of the
square on the bottom right corner we can
construct a congruent Square where its
side length is also equal to R let the
coin roll on the right side of the
square and we can construct another
square with a side length equal to R let
the coin roll on the top side and we
construct a forward square with a side
length equal to
R the coin then rolls on the left side
of the square and returns to its
starting position with one whole
Revolution since it has made one whole
Revolution we know that on each side it
is made a quarter
turn so exactly 1/4 of the circumference
is spanned by this distance between the
two
squares so the length between these two
squares is equal to the circumference of
the coin / 4 which equals 2 pi r / 4 and
that equals < R /
2 so the entire Square side length is
equal to r + r + p piun r / 2 factoring
out the r gives R multiplied 2 + piun /
2 in this problem R is equal to 1 which
means the side of the square is equal to
2 + Pi / 2 and that's the answer to
problem
one
now let's solve problem
two so first let's construct a rectangle
whose side length is equal to the
smaller cords
length then construct a diameter of the
circle and notice we have a symmetry
everything to the left side of this
diameter is the same as everything to
the right side they are congruent to be
more precise the diameter is the
perpendicular bis sector of the upper
and lower cord so so on the upper chord
this left side is exactly equal to this
right side on the bottom chord the left
side is exactly equal to the right side
so if we take the length of half the
upper chord minus half the lower chord
we end up with this length on the left
side and it will exactly be the same
length on the right
side so if we construct this rectangle
on the left side of the circle we know
that one of its lengths will be equal to
12 - 8 equal
4 by symmetry we can exactly translate
this over to the right side of the
circle this length will also be equal to
four so on the bottom side we can bring
down this 24 so we have a length of four
and the remaining length will be 24
minus 4 which equal 20 we'll do the same
Construction in the other Circle
construct a rectangle whose one side
length is equal to the smaller chord of
the
circle then we divide the circle right
down the middle so we have symmetry on
both sides we construct this rectangle
and we can see that one side length is
equal to 26 minus 20 which equal six we
bring this rectangle over to the other
side of the circle and now let's say the
missing length is equal to X so we have
6 + x is equal to 22 and that means X is
equal to 16 and that's the answer to
problem
two so now let's solve problem
three the first thing we'll do is we'll
calculate the side lengths of each
Square so the square with area of 16
will have a side length that's equal to
four the square with area of 100 will
have a side length equal to 10 the
square with Area 25 will have a side
length equal to
five finally let the rest of this chord
have a side length that's equal to
X let's focus just on these two chords
of the circle by the chord chord power
theorem we have 5 * X is equal to 4 * 10
so 5x is equal to 40 and X is equal to
8 let's now do another
construction along this chord let's go
up four units and then then construct a
parallel chord that's congruent to the
other horizontal
chord the remaining distance will be 10
- 4 which is equal to
6 we will then complete a rectangle this
length will also be equal to six now
since we have a rectangle we have a
right angle here and that means these
two chords will subtend the diameter of
the
circle so this chord will be a diameter
under the circle and its length will be
equal to 2
R we now have a right triangle where the
hypotenuse is equal to 2 R one leg is
equal to 6 and the other leg is equal to
8 + 5 which equal
13 we'll just focus on this right
triangle we have 6^ 2 + 132 is equal to
the square of 2 R this means 2005 is
equal to 4 R 2 and thus R 2 is equal to
51.2 multiplying both sides of the
equation by pi gives pi r squared which
is the area of the circle is equal to
51.2 Pi and that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time
oh